تجمع المتظاهرون هنا في وسط
لندن في سفارة ميانمار
ضد الديكتاتورية العسكرية
وقتل المدنيين ودعمًا للسفير الذي
تم حظره من المبنى منذ
مساء الأربعاء ،
تخبرنا المصادر أن التوترات كانت
تحتدم بين السفير الذي
أخذ  وقفة علنية ضد المجلس العسكري
وغيره من كبار أعضاء
السفارة بمن فيهم
الرجل الثاني والملحق العسكري الذي
دعم الحملة العسكرية في
ميانمار
لدرجة أن السفير قام
بوضع أقفال على أبواب السفارة في
الآونة الأخيرة  أيام لمنع الاستيلاء ،
هذا هو بالضبط ما حدث
عندما جاء إلى هنا ليلة الأربعاء ،
بقي الباب مغلقًا ، وكان مغلقًا
من المبنى الذي كان أعضاء في
جيش ميانمار منذ ذلك الحين قد استولوا عليه بكل النوايا والأغراض ،
وكان السفير كوزوي
مين هنا.  قبل فترة وجيزة
دعا السلطات البريطانية إلى إزالة
أولئك الذين استولوا على السفارة
التي يخاطبها  إد الاحتجاج المؤيد للديمقراطية
هنا
يرفع ثلاثة أصابع في الهواء
علامة على العصيان
المدني ومقاومة المجلس العسكري في
ميانمار
سيريل فانيير سي إن إن لندن